c'est une question de mois maintenant
entre mars et avril 2020 le centre
commercial open sky 2 plaisir va ouvrir
ses portes
une trentaine d'enseignants sera
installé au sein de cette infrastructure
ici nous sommes dans la galerie
marchande dans cette danse est belle
galerie qui sera couverte par une
toiture en dans une matière qu'on
appelle le tf qui est une matière qui
est à la fois protéger la pluie mais
permet la transparence
les premiers magasins sont en train
d'être livré aux preneurs c'est le cas
notamment de prat et marque la cellule
qui est tout au fond vers moi et donc
qui travaillent mais qui commence
maintenant c'est cette phase
d'aménagement pour les différents
magasins l'aménagement intérieur
alors que le reste du chantier est en
train de lui d'être d'être complétée est
terminée et des baies vitrées du marbre
sur les façades 200 personnes
travaillent actuellement sur le chantier
d'un côté une zone commerciale fermé et
de l'autre une partie ouverte sur
l'extérieur juste derrière moi se
trouvera un moment l'ouverture un
escalier monumental qui descendra
jusqu'à la partie ouverte la partie
retail park du projet avec en bas
un petit miroir d'eau autour duquel
s'articulera une zone de restauration on
voit la structure métallique est en
train d'être montés sur laquelle va
venir se positionner ce qu'on appelle la
vêture du bâtiment c'est à dire son
enveloppe extérieure ce qui sera
vraiment vu par les utilisateurs qui
arrivent par la route
là vous êtes en train de faire le trajet
qui effectuera un véhicule en arrivant
sur ce site en empruntant les allées
pour aller vers les parkings souterrains
opensky va renforcer le dynamisme de la
zone commerciale plaisir les clayes sous
bois
à la clé plus de 300 emplois vont être
créés